president Trump's Navy secretary says he
was fired in the controversy over a Navy
SEAL because the president gave him an
order he couldn't in good conscience
carry out Secretary Richard Spencer's
removal follows a dispute that began
when the president reversed the Navy's
demotion of Edward Gallagher Gallagher
was convicted of posing with a dead Isis
fighter in Iraq he was also accused of
murdering a prisoner of war but was
acquitted of that charge David Martin is
at the Pentagon David what's the
response there good morning well
Spencer's boss defense secretary Mark
espera says he fired Spencer due to
losing trust and confidence in him
because of a lack of candor
either way the case of the Navy vs.
Edward Gallagher has now turned into a
full-blown fiasco complete with
conflicting accounts of why the Navy
secretary had to go Spencer was fired a
day after denying reports he might
resign over the Gallagher affair I have
not threatened to resign I am here I
work at the pleasure of the President
defense secretary mark espera said that
Spencer had gone behind his back to
negotiate with the White House on ways
to short-circuit disciplinary
proceedings against Gallagher last week
the president tweeted the Navy will not
be taking Gallagher's Trident pin the
symbol of his status as an elite Navy
SEAL Spencer said he needed to see an
order in writing from the president
before stopping Gallagher's appearance
before a review board that could have
kicked him out of the elite unit if the
president requests to stop the process
the process stops but Spencer's
resignation letter made it sound like he
was fired before he could embarrass the
president by resigning on principle he
wrote I cannot in good conscience obey
an order that I believe violates the
sacred oath I took for his part
President Trump tweeted he was not
pleased with the way the Navy handled
the Gallagher case and with Spencers
inability to manage cost overruns on
big-ticket items like a new aircraft
carrier that kept a day in which
Gallagher appeared on Fox News
made openly insubordinate statements
about his superior officers this is all
about ego and retaliation this has
nothing to do with good order and
discipline in addition to firing Spenser
defense secretary Esper also directed
that Gallagher be allowed to keep his
Triton in the statement to Fox News
Gallagher thanked the president for
stepping in and quote correcting all the
wrongs that had been done to him
Yurika David Martin thank you